an urgent motion passed during an urgent
session in parliament on tuesday
251 parliamentarians are demanding that
the government
stop unrestricted access by iaea's
inspectors to iranian nuclear sites
this draft bill would also oblige iran's
atomic energy organization
to take uranium enrichment to 20
it is now at 4.5 percent and under the
2015 nuclear agreement
iran should be producing enriched
uranium at only 3.67 percent
the majority indeed sends the message to
the enemies of iran that this one-sided
game is over
this motion will now have to go to the
guardian council for approval
but all decisions about iran's nuclear
program are made by another body
that's the supreme national security
council but this move by the
conservatively controlled parliament
comes at a critical time on friday
sixty-three-year-old nuclear scientist
mohsen fakhri zadeh
was assassinated near tehran when his
motorcade came
under attack in broad daylight in a rare
move
the government released these
never-before-seen photos of fakhrizadeh
receiving the order of service for his
role in the 2015 nuclear deal
a fact which was not public knowledge
until now
in 2018 u.s president donald trump
withdrew from the deal and imposed a
series of crippling
economic penalties on iran as a result
iran reduced his commitments to the deal
in phases
and the access to international atomic
energy inspectors
is all of what remains as part of the
jcpoa deal
there is a lot of pressure on the
government inside iran to respond to the
assassination
of one of the country's top nuclear and
defense officials
i think it's uh quite telling indicating
the fact
that iran's uh or the iranian debates on
the jcpoa
uh moving to a harsher uh you know
situation and rhetoric i think will
this will have an effect on the future
dialogues and
negotiations on the jcpoa and the
compliance with it
tuesday's motion allows the government
one month to implement these demands
article 176 of the iranian constitution
states it is a matter beyond the three
branches of government or the
legislative body which is the megalis
no political body or branch of power
could act beyond that
the latest iaea report which came out in
november
said that iran now has 12 times more
than the permitted amount of 300
kilograms of enriched uranium
putting its stockpile at nearly 4 000
kilograms
the killing of most and fakuzade and now
this motion in parliament are all just
adding pressure
to the rohani administration in the last
few months that they have left in office
president hassan rouhani has already
said that iran will avenge the death
of the higher ranking official but
what's clear now is that he doesn't want
to use the nuclear agreement
to do so dorothy barry al jazeera
tehran